in the world of cars there are Ferraris
and then there are Ferrari the $320,000
Ferrari f12berlinetta
is decidedly the latter we are in the
Mojave Desert in the middle of a wind
farm and it's the perfect juxtaposition
to this 12 cylinder gas guzzling f12
Berlinetta it gets an astounding 731
horsepower and it'll hit 62 miles per
hour at 3.1 seconds
everything in this car is oriented
toward making me want to go faster
this is the car that Ferrari made to
drive to the track drive on the track
and then drive home from the track
I'm also really happy to report that the
interior is big there's lots of head and
leg room there's plenty of shoulder room
these are racing style sports seats that
are adjustable in a dozen ways you're
gonna be fine with them there are a few
blind spots behind your rear left and
right corners and don't expect to take
this car over any dips higher than speed
oh and expect to get no more than 18
miles per gallon tops but those are
small prices to pay for near perfection
in the driving machine Ferrari is
extremely proud of what it has achieved
with this modern Berlinetta and
rightfully so it's the most powerful
Ferrari Road car ever built I loved it
to my mind the Ferrari California is the
car you buy your spouse or your son the
f12 berlinetta this is the one you'll
want to keep for yourself